[Music]
a lot of you at home wonder Luke how do
you do it all this traveling with three
small children that must be exhausting
and I love is it oh I'm a big ball of
you MINIX wet I dunno but we're having
fun anyways just roll with it
but a rate we got to get everything
packed we started off with so much room
in the back of this car we were so proud
of ourselves it is absolutely to the
gills if we get in a car right it'll
take the jaws of life to pry us free
from our luggage oh but we're gonna go
to Baton Rouge Louisiana first for me
and I think I have first for you all
right to Louisiana everybody
in Louisiana we had no plans to do that
gentlemen three hours ago cowboy boots I
saw your dad got you some oh my goodness
look at that place head that's crazy
daddy wants to check the water out well
our friends live on this long and skinny
Lake and we do not have a clue what
lives in this Lake they told me it's
stocked but they don't fish they don't
know what it's stocked with presume it's
got Basinger but I am very curious to
see what's in this Lake and see if we
can catch something because if we could
that would be way cool whoo it is hot
right now
Oh feels like it's in the 90s you might
get ourselves situated and unpacked once
it cools down a little bit then all
right guys so we're here with the levant
and they say they have an awesome place
to eat here Baton Rouge she wants it in
this place Sammy's okay we're gonna go
check out Sammy's you guys ready all
right we got seven kids and for adults
we are going to destroy this place okay
Lee what's good here man what's good the
crawfish is good
[Music]
fried green tomatoes alligator bites and
fried pickles there this is gonna be
good
you know got some alley here tomato I
got fried pork chops with beans and rice
and cornbread
crawfish etouffee look at that that
looks delicious well guys we have tore
it up here man this is excellent food
and Beck has got some dessert here it's
a blueberry white chocolate deep-fried
bread pudding that's that's pretty
amazing
guys we got ourselves not one not two
but many doggy bags this is the
definition of eyes bigger than your
stomach and my stomach is very big today
well you guys get a good night's rest
and be really good boys so we can go and
have adventures tomorrow good night it's
a gorgeous morning and it is not too hot
quite yet but man it's getting there
quickly it's about 7:00 in the morning
and that feels like it's already in the
70s maybe low 80s it's gonna get up
close to a hundred today I'm sure but
damn I really quick throw some rods out
and see if we can't catch something out
of this little lake behind the house try
that out see what happens good morning
Nathan do you want to catch a fish let's
see what we got at the bull head okay
hold it kind of squeeze a little bit
congratulations Acadia is that your
first catfish yeah
all right nice little bull head there
you go hey Abigail come here hey
relighted oh that's a nice fish see
that's the biggest one we've seen so far
keep your rod up in the air put your rod
tip over there like that yeah there it
is
well Gigi congratulations that is a
respectable bass that feels like he's
two pounds maybe three look good job
shall we put him back all right did you
let's go there yeah let's hope let's put
him back
watch the throw him back put him in
gently
[Music]
there we go hold on go ahead and reel
that sucker in oh it's a bluegill
yeah bluegill look at that get is this
fun you join this yeah this is a fun
place you guys could catch a lot of fish
back here well guys we had an absolute
ball the girls had a great time I knew
that was the first fish for a lot of
them but we're out of bait so that's it
but they were telling me that they
didn't have any fishing gear and so I'm
gonna do a little something I'm gonna
run to Walmart and I'm gonna go get them
some cheap little rod and reel combos
and get them all set up to fish this
spot so they come down here and fish in
their backyard wherever they want to Wow
look at that
yeah that's gravedigger yeah if you're
gonna buy a little setup for kids and
you want to do a really nice one these
Epico doc Diamond deluxe is hard to beat
for the price all right we can't forget
a pink tackle box - that's gonna be good
I'm excited to show them this fishing
gear I think they're gonna like it check
these out
I'll show you how to use it instead of
electronic bite alarms we're gonna go
old-school we got a fork stick all right
there we go
and throw it okay there you go
you reel it in you know put it on your
little rod holder like dad okay but a
big fin if a fish comes along it'll grab
it and pull into the water so take this
other stick put it right there and shove
it down the ground and the fish grabs it
can't take it away got it okay you come
in you catch anything you start
hollering we'll come out and help you
get it off the hook
sweating man giving you a I'm gonna miss
you
[Music]
we are going to have a truly Cajun Bayou
experience we are going to spend all
night hunting frogs crawfish catfish the
whole thing we are going to be out in
the Bayou all night long
doing what we were meant to do all time
we meet mr. Kevin
oh man look at that that's a nice setup
well you know one up good good tom
thanks guys we were here at the Cajun
experience base camp and this is blowing
my mind I kind of signed up for this
without really knowing what I was
getting into but I came out here and
this is an amazing base camp we got
three of these houseboats kind of tied
together here and check this out folks
look at this
got a great dining area here kitchen
getting prepared up all your food got
fishing rods all sorts of stuff check
this out
got on a nice guest cabin here oh I see
cooled air conditioning it's like 95
degrees outside right now we got a nice
bathroom and shower kitchen and dining
area here and look at this got a bunch
of bunk beds
brand-new Union Tommy are the first
people to stay in it
and look at this
[Music]
this is amazing folks I if I hadn't
known gonna be this nice I would have
brought Becca and Jacob and all of them
well guys here in a few minutes we're
gonna go off and get some crawfish and I
haven't caught and eating my own
crawfish in years and I am so jazzed to
do this okay but
oh yeah that's that's the money right
there pulling that one up all by
yourself buddy Tommy are you having a
ball catching these crawdads Tommy was
not so jazzed on touching these at first
but he has really come around look at
that excited to eat these
anytime you want to rate this out
that's an alligator you'd like it is it
tasty my son who is 5 years old and only
likes 3 things in the whole world just
finished off like a full basket of
alligator
holy mackerel we're gonna have to make
some alligator at home if this is iffy
there's one thing to get a DJ now she
always oh my goodness hopeful guys check
this out I don't think you get better
food man these fresh products a lot of
minutes ago look it out over the Bayou
this is pretty nice
well guys we just finished an awesome
dinner and we got a few hours before
sunset we're gonna throw out a couple
jug lines here for catfish see what
happens Tommy's in natural throwing jug
lines here he's showing up his old man
here ready buddy
this is juggling we got a pool noodle
here got a little three-way not that
looks like about a six on hook here and
some paracord at the end of the paracord
we got a bit of anger buddy way to go
taking them out all right man let's go
get you a nap
[Music]
got it that's my very first alligator
gar ain't setting any records but man it
was totally jump clean out of the water
that is a wicked set of chompers oh yeah
yeah I've got a heart sheet tongue
you're lucky I'm a merciful and
benevolent fisherman here you Tommy
buddy oh you already go frog hunting
alright guys it's midnight on the
opening day of frog hunting season and
we are excited we are excited I've been
wanting to do this for a long time and
Tommy's pretty jazzed to
right now with goose around checking our
jug lines and these headlamps are
amazing we can see into the bayou
and looking for the little eyes of the
frogs we're gonna try to drive up on
them and grab them with our hands you
can also see alligator eyes and all
sorts of creepy crawlies it's this is
really cool being out here at night
there's something kind of green shining
right there spider spider eyes that is
awesome
put him in that hole there you go buddy
guys I just caught my first bullfrog I
am so stoked I got I got my bullfrog
skunk off all right guys this is on like
Donkey Kong
[Music]
there is so much awesome stuff out here
that I just can't get on film to the
darkness and I mean we're seeing
thousands of spider eyes in the grass
spider eyes it's crazy and we alligators
everywhere and we're just having a ball
oh yeah healthy he's all yours
apparently I'm only good to get him in
the boat Tommy high five
she doing great buddy okay you gotta
gotta stay hydrated this is hardcore
froggen [ __ ] slap slap frogs lamp
[Music]
[Music]
bro absolutely yeah look at a big old
alley here this is pretty cool that you
gonna spend a Thursday night catching
frogs with your dad in the Bayou did you
have an awesome time come on there we go
but I love frogs oh oh look at these
look at the size of these suckers check
that beast out man
[Music]
we're gonna eat those Wow
now Tommy we told you we're gonna eat a
buddy oh look at that that is soft soft
meat probably fish - whoo
and let it go
there you
oh man that's good look at that that is
a pile of food right there alright guys
here's my very very first frog leg here
I know it's a cliche but does it taste
like taking does it more tender than
chicken that's for sure how do I think
even my wife's gonna like that thank you
very much it has been an amazing night
and I am exhausted about 2:30 in the
morning and I've got a belly full of
fried frog fried catfish and crawfish
and Tommy's totally zoned out so I'm
gonna get some sleep and I will see you
guys in the morning
well guys got a little shut-eye last
night woke up nice and refreshed and
this is my view outside the bunkhouse I
can't emphasize enough guys how awesome
of it an experience this was and how
family-friendly this is the boat rides
amazing the scenery is amazing the
bunkhouse is comfortable and nice and
air-conditioned you know if you're not
into frog hunting if you don't even want
to touch a frog you could come out here
and have a ball and eat delicious food
and just wake up to this so if you want
to try this out guys look up Cajun
experience this company is amazing and
you've got to go with these guys before
they figure out they're grossly under
charging you yeah this is very very
affordable I'll put links in the
description to the Facebook page their
websites the whole thing so check it out
guys man these guys know how to treat a
fellow got breakfast
bacon and eggs and rolls not a bad way
to end the lovely trip delegator Oh
sit down but it's an alligator I got a
feeling we will be hearing that for the
next 18 hours a drive Tommy that was
awesome
that was probably the most fun I've ever
had on a fishing trip you have a good
time buddy
so you ready to go see mommy and Nathan
Jacob all right well guys I am exhausted
but there is no rest for the wicked and
we are gonna go out to an alligator park
I'm gonna try and ever remain upright
[Music]
[Music]
Nicole I think it's important you know
that I school the crap out of your
daughters and businessing along trivia
we're here at Cajun village in Baton
Rouge Louisiana apparently they have
beignets alligators and souvenirs a
trifecta of things that we are all
interested in today this is a beignet
right here it's a deep-fried pastry with
lots of sugar on it very traditional
down here in Louisiana
I'll leave that big guy
well the alligators were way cool
now we're gonna go check out the
souvenir shop
all right Becky you wanna try these frog
legs the key is just to imagine what it
looked like when it was alive and then
bite in all right guys I got a young
lady here who really wants to do some
fishing so with our last night here
we're gonna get her a fish on her
fishing gear sure just wash your hands
really good afterwards gentle all right
come on here pull them up the bigger one
look at him all right there we go nice
little ball head okay there we go
fishing at nights a lot better than
fishing in the middle of the day isn't
it
so you think you can do this on your own
catch fish on your own I bet you can't -
well we had a great time cooking up frog
legs catching fish on the back yard but
it is late I'm exhausted the kids are
already past their bedtime which was a
massive strategic error on my part but
we shall get a good night's rest and
then tomorrow we're heading to Virginia
hey guys we're here at Frank's and we're
gonna grab some breakfast this place
looks pretty hoppin so some pretty high
expectations but let's load up on some
food
[Music]
all right guys got breakfast here my boy
Payton man is helping me out got too
much food we got blueberry stuffed
french toast we've got sweet potato
pancakes normal pancakes
that's a biscuits and gravy and grits
and eggs man we're ready to roll we are
sad to leave but it is time to go oh my
goodness
16 hours 15 minutes babe you ready to do
this all right if you'd like to see more
great outdoor boys videos including all
the videos from this southern road trip
check out the link in the description
and don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos every week and join
us every Saturday morning for a new
adventure from the outdoor boys thanks
for watching
[Music]